d'abord je pense que les raisons pour
lesquelles un certain nombre de gens
veulent converger vers paris lassitude
des restrictions si j'ai peur j'ai peur
que le ras-le-bol dans le pays recréer
les conditions du mouvement des gilet
jaune il ya le prix des carburants la
cherté du coût de la vie il ya aussi le
ras-le-bol de ces mesures sanitaires qui
ne sont plus compris enfin c'est le
docteur fischer convient qu'on vient
faire parler sur le sur le pass
vaccinale tout le monde sait très bien
qu'ils n'empêchent pas la contamination
tout le monde le sait même
scientifiquement non validés une espèce
de feuilleton âge en vue en vue de la
levée des restrictions avant la
présidentielle sur le convoi le convoi
lui-même la liberté parfois moi moi je
respecte tout la liberté d'expression
des personnes j'ai jamais choisi sa
viabilisation moi moi j'ai jamais choisi
d'aller dans la rue pour me battre
contre contre le passage idéal pass
vaccinale mon combat il est ici
maintenant le préfet de police de paris
x et son dos et son travail de faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de débordements
attention à rappeler à l'époque du dd
gilet jaune on a dû envoyer les
parlementaires sur le terrain demandé au
maire de mener le grand débat faire
retomber la pression jeudi au
gouvernement de faire attention et bien
se mettre en mode écoute de ce qui se
passe dans le pays y compris sur ce qui
n'est pas du sanitaire sur ce qui est
aussi due de l'économique et social
parce que l'élection est dans pas
longtemps enfin les élections
présidentielles puis législatives
il s'agirait pas d'abord un pays apaisé
sur la première un plan sanitaire pour
avoir à nouveau une forme de bronx
économique et social c'est ça donc le
président gouvernement il faut qu'ils se
mettent en mode écoute oui hélas non du
preuve révèle police elle est peut-être
de nature à rajouter un peu d'huile sur
le feu voyez ce jeudi le reste
[Musique]